you have a sneeze and tickle your
butthole at the same time which it's
weird pulsates like a little amoeba I
don't do that
Oh what is going on you sexy pit-stained
that's a new one
there's a certain muscle group that I
hate when it's sword and that's your abs
now when it comes to working out I
rarely isolate my uh abdominis muscular
Linus door slightest that's scientific
term why you ask is because I do a lot
of compound exercises that naturally
tighten my core but as it turns out when
you workout and isolate the muscle by
itself oh my god
between you and me I farted yesterday
and um I think that or something let me
ask you guys a question you guys ever
get pissed off at your own fart for
attacking you I farted and that [ __ ]
exploded in my nostrils like a Chinese
firecracker now there's a golden rule
known in nature your fart is not
supposed to attack you it's supposed to
be like a watchdog that bites
everybody else but you I don't know if I
told you all this but if you scare me
enough I can fart on command
it's my defense mechanism you know what
I call AB soreness I call it the thief
of joy because we don't know what your
store what are the worst things to do is
laugh if you guys can't tell already I
smile a stupid amount do you have any
idea how weird you look when you laugh
suddenly turns into tears ha I look my
polish but on a side note when I was a
kid I used to think that uh bipolar
meant that you had to pull the bearers
for pets I had no friends but you all
know the worst thing that could happen
when you add the sword is a sneeze dummy
a sneeze is it like a grenade going off
in your bellybutton Oh
one of my biggest fears throughout the
day now is sneezing man is so sad you
know this morning I was supposed to get
the mail but it was next to this
rosebush so I was like [ __ ] it the way I
was on you would have sworn those rose
bushes were a bunch of Mexican [ __ ] stop
Gino come here for so I can like
aggravate your sinuses and [ __ ] now it's
time for workout of the week and this
week is all about Barre complexes hey
look son you in a band what the [ __ ] now
this is a compound workout to the mask
and my nickname for this workout is
actually the cactus but [ __ ]
now if you notice a lot of the workouts
that I do I don't focus on a small
isolated muscle group for me I'd like to
do compound workouts burn a lot of
calories in a quick amount of time
I do workouts that may work out a core
muscle group but along with the
movements they also work out the an
ciliary muscles that come along with it
that's a big-ass [ __ ] more than
celery so for example if I'm doing lat
pull-downs or pull-ups not only am i
working out my back when I'm pulling
myself up I'm also working out my bicep
the back is the core muscle group that
is burning a lot of calories but in turn
I'm also working out this right here so
as you can see in this clip a bear
complex incorporates a lot of movements
it incorporates a deadlift a clean to a
front squat to a shoulder press to a
back squat back to another shoulder
press for me it was hard to get a proper
clean and number one because I was out
of practice
and number two the weight was really
light but that's the weight that I had
to use because I couldn't show the press
anymore than that so if something that I
will work on in the future and I will
get better at it and if you notice with
this workout you are not allowed to let
go the weights you just touch and go and
you start back up with your rep until
you're finished with your sake now if
you do not know how to deadlift front
squat back squat or clean properly do
not even try this because you will hurt
yourself literally your vagina and your
penis will explode it is all over the
map it's all about safety first because
you don't want to be in my position
where I didn't know what the [ __ ] I was
doing and I just obliterated my body and
now look at me
mmm so until next time funny fat fit fam
remember life is always what you make it
but it's up to you to take what you
deserve let's go for broke
Oh what is going on YouTube so hope you
guys enjoyed that episode of
fit and remember if you guys want to
copy gear you can go ahead and go for
broke apparel calm and get the shirt
such a says cuz I feel bad
now remember [ __ ] bad fit is here
every Wednesday and if you are doing
this with me make sure you make your own
videos and if you don't want to do that
do it on Instagram post pictures and
hash tag FFF hashtag funny fat fit I
will be there periodically to check up
on you guys give you guys are like or
maybe even leave a comment cuz I'm here
to support you let's do better and as
always there will be another video on
Sunday ready and willing for you guys to
check out and Pete my trigger so I will
see you all then Sunday and Wednesday
peace well you why you ask because I do
a lot of compound exercises and then
when you're hanging in there worst thing
is that gonna what the [ __ ] am I trying
to say put that may work out a core
hanging ringing implement but you got no
when you could have come around you we
know you when you come around you Duty
anyone remember life is always what you
make it but it's up freaky
mmm that's not even the same back squat
then again to another